reporter wird ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution und nachher gibt
es noch ein bisschen öl
gott segne dich im namen gottes des
vaters und des sohnes und des heiligen
geist das thema warum also warum machst
du solltest direkten ist wenn ich so im
vordergrund standen sich dann erzählen
haben so ich mache es ist rührend stieg
und ich bin faul der pfarrer und die
krokodile untypischen bringen werden wir
mehr so begegnet anstoßen
500 jahre nach der reformation ist die
kirche abgemagert pfarrer christian
walther will sie aufpäppeln
im spagat zwischen tradition und moderne
er finde also einen beruf ständig neue
struktur her irgendwann irgendwie kein
neues zu probieren
doch mit welchen mitteln will der
umtriebige junge mann diesen wandel
ankurbeln
[Musik]
gibt es so etwas wie ein rezept um die
kirche wieder attraktiv zu machen
neun monate mit christian walther
[Musik]
das mega cool
januar im pfarrhaus der friedenskirche
bern das experiment heute das dev kaffee
zusammen mit humor trainerin salome in
einer quartier bar soll zum sechsten mal
über den tod gesprochen werden
ob man menschen durch wein und kurz lee
dem tod und so indirekt der kirche näher
bringt einen versuch ist es wert um auch
mit jüngeren menschen in kontakt zu
kommen
so wie sie zur olli und der löffel sind
bereit
dieser wird in der diskussion abgegeben
wichtig wäre mal ist eigentlich alles
schon vorbestimmt wie in ihrem
aussterben oder können wir überhaupt
irgendetwas vor bestimmen
vielleicht hat er sich schon sehr
überlegt zu dem thema wie erwartet oder
sie wird aber nicht alles machen was
gewöhnlich ich mich riesig auf das
experiment funktioniert und pariert im
schutz der bar trauen sich die menschen
dem tabuthema tod etwas raum zu geben
[Musik]
seit drei jahren waltet der 35-jährige
wald die an der friedenskirche auf einem
hügel cronenberg der massige sakralbau
eher abschreckend als einladend doch
herausforderungen haben christian wald
die schon immer gereizt und internet da
habe ich immer das gefühl kroos sage ich
gleich den richtigen orte gibt die
flächen braucht lüth wo sachen andere
sache machen
der zürcher genießt seine stellung als
freundliche ruhestörer in bern
es gibt viel zu tun zum beispiel einen
flexibleren zugang zur kirche zu
ermöglichen
der handfläche länder zum teil hat die
katholische hand viel flexiblere
strukturen manchen wochenenden geld
zurück oder was leute wohnen oder einen
ort wo sie schaffen zum beispiel oder
was ich so schicken mir freunde haben
und das ist viel flexibler und das ist
im moment noch lustig er hätte von mir
trainer gibt es halt ich hörte dass wir
das so mosler und die kinder selber so
reformiert und und flexibel jeder form
land die chance nutzt die
branchenstruktur zwei andere extrem
stört
auch im pfarrhaus neben der kirche hat
wald die beim einzug vor drei jahren
alte zöpfe abgeschnitten
das große gebäude sei nicht für die
moderne konzipiert für einzelpersonen zu
teuer
kurzerhand hat der geschiedene junge
mann eine wg gegründet die schon viel
wechseln gesehen hat möglich sind auch
die metal szene abgrund ich habe dich
noch nie in der schule habe ich nicht
interessiert wieso philosophische themen
so aber ich habe nie gedacht dass man
das aus beruf machen kann ich habe
gedacht ich muss dann irgendwann einmal
in einer bank arbeiten hier ist im
studium habe ich diesen glauben richtig
kennengelernt sage ich erst so und habe
mich immer mehr begeistert und ich habe
auch gemerkt so ich kann das noch gut
christian walti gibt bereitwillig
antwort er redet gerne und gut und
scheint die menschen um sich herum auch
zu brauchen
er sei nicht gemacht für das leben
allein leidet wenn es brüche gibt brooks
ist schwierig sich dass die erste wege
sich so auf größte hat sie geschwiegen
und beziehe so wichtig dass die mühe
haben beziehung beziehung funktioniert
oder lang auch so das finde wirklich
schwieriger es gibt gute gründe rum oder
das kurze glück liebe und ich mag es
nicht ohne dass sie ihre wohnung
gefunden aber die neue partnerschaften
oder sei aber dass das dann so aus dass
meine filme oder
schöns schöne bezirksliga hatte später
besuche ich christian bald die im
gottesdienst ein großes team und achsen
traditionell also 60 grad waschen und
gleichzeitig sind mancher trainer setzt
jetzt sind ganz normale moderne mensch
irgendwann klick stars wie jetzt dann um
1 80 moderner gottesdienst machen
denn weil sie vielleicht weniger fremd
aber sie hat einen speziellen methode
der junge er neuerer zeit sich hier
überraschend traditionell symbolik und
rituale schaut er auch gerne bei den
katholiken ab daneben braucht es aber
auch neue ideen
heute ist eine gemeinde vom land
eingeladen
zusätzlich sorgt die tauf gemeinschaft
um den kleinen andrehen für etwas
volleren bank
so geht hin in frieden des dreieinigen
gottes des vaters und des sohnes und des
heiligen geistes
zur traditionellen farblicht gehört auch
das ständige offene ohr für die
mitmenschen die vielen freiwilligen oder
die seelsorge bestellt und offenbar
immer wieder verdient gehört das für
wichtig dass geht es dir dort bis es ist
nicht einfach das wurde auch schon der
ärger sorgen dass das fehlende wirklich
großartig aussehen glüht der biblisch
die haut und die machen und sich abends
leistete aber so ganz kann nicht so mit
dem fahrer das hat sich so einig dass
diese person ist wo zuerst ohne zweite
ohne irgendeinen hintergedanken und und
daher probierten wir sie zu stark das
ist eben der sorgende das schien recht
gut funktionieren obwohl viele vor der
viele serien freunde sind haben sich vor
der sonne nicht unter überlegt stunde
und schönes berührt immer wieder muss
sich christian wald die in erinnerung
rufen es gibt keinen alleingang in der
reformierten kirche teamplayer sein
gehört auch ins pflichtenheft der
ungeduldigen darum gibt es sitzungen und
immer wieder sitzungen haupttraktandum
der heutigen partie sitzung die
neugestaltung des altars
meisten aber und jetzt geht's los wie
steve jobs ist das büro meist sogar
schmuck nur grau und rot weiß jetzt dass
ich bin hier auf dem tisch liegt und
jetzt - ohne und der sieht da hingen
oder wobei jetzt peter nowak im umland
wie sein weil es bei uns kosten können
das problem vom ton her stammen
[Musik]
das ist hier vielleicht kommen der usa
ich glaube grundsätzlich begeisterte
volker smid die möglichkeiten gebe
koordination projekte strukturreform
unzählige sitzungen ein potpourri aus
meinungen der pfarrer sei häufig im
zwiespalt müsse sensibel sein aber auch
grenzen überschreiten
ich hoffe so minimiert das mache und auf
verschiedene strategien abwarten und
zuschauen wie andere schickt wie sieht
so ein mann ich sage sogar ja taktik das
gerät hatte ich gerade so ich mache bei
sony alle voll umfänglich zu informieren
was ich mache und rechnet damit dass ich
von einer lügt verwirrt
bis jetzt ist immer gut ausgegangen und
ich glaube es ist also wie luftfahrer
magische grenze überschritten
im bereich wird sich die kirche müsse
ihre positionen verharren
christian liebt orte im umbruch orte die
sich verändern lassen wie die brache
warmbach lief für deren kreative
zwischennutzung er sich als
vereins-präsident einsetzt
gott ist für die ewigkeit auf erden
liegt der junge pfarrer das temporäre
super ernsthaft oder also dass ich
verstehe es gut dass diesmal projekt das
ist nicht komisch mir völlig da auto und
investiert jetzt seine ganze energie und
cooler zwei monate sind vergangen seit
meinem letzten besuch eine zeit des
umbruchs auch in seinem privatleben
christian wald die ist mit seiner
partnerin zusammengezogen und papa
geworden durch seinen aktivismus ist
ungebremst
das schon persönlich als technisch nicht
möglich war klar besser unter dem namen
oder so ein unternehmer muss seine ware
verkaufen risiken eingehen präsenz
markieren
das mache die reformierte kirche zu
wenig ich begleite christian wald die
bei seinem nächsten experiment mit der
freiwilligen helferin anna wie der heute
fremde füße waschen auf dem europaplatz
in bern dass jesus seine jünger fürs
klasse haben sozusagen der meisten
großen muskeln und und wir sind ja meist
riet rack und dann mache ich das mache
ich nicht so angenehm ist aber
brandenburg drückt und strahlen das ist
ziemlich intim meditieren vielleicht und
das ist man irritiert sind der manager
gesagt bis möchte
doch die araber und ok größte show fürs
waschen
ja ich mache auch ich mache kostet
nichts eigentlich weist eine an ein
christ aus dem quartier im austausch mit
menschen ist christian ganz bei sich die
begegnungen geben ihm auch zuversicht
auch in seinem blauen die gläubige
person was gibt sehr viele so moment da
bin ich schon froh dass andere um sich
gedanken experiment machen
ich war der letzte mensch der welt das
glaubt und alle anderen rund um die
klage gar nicht probiert die ständig von
anif überzeugt es wäre mir egal
das mache ich nun heute nicht jeden tag
in meinem beruf ist sonst etwas anderes
okay heute der erste fuß bitte und geld
sie ist angenehm
ja bist du ein praktizierender muslim
oder bist du eine andere religion okay
gut dann bin ich vielleicht sogar muss
ist die gleiche währung das ist sehr
schön
aber verändern vier gewaschene füße die
kirche ich das nicht etwas zufällig die
volkskirche müsse genau das in kleinen
zu nachdenken anregen
wir können recht miteinander rum was
habe ich nur für traditionen
was ist wichtig im zwischenmenschlichen
noten zum beispiel was ich in tralee
gehäuse dialog oder das finde ich so
mein akku sollen sie mit dem haus der
religionen oder das ist eine coole
institution und da findet ganz ganz
interessante konferenz statt wo die
religion zu treffen miteinander über
große theologische frage rettet aber ich
weiß nicht wie ihr jemals für die jemals
mit einem ganz normalen kaffee trinken
oder was ist für mich in die religiöse
dialog auf
ich finde das nicht richtig sache und
man macht und was erreichen sind
experimentell und experimenten immer
zufällig musste sie aber dass es jetzt
machen es gab ziemlich nah
aufgabenbereich
september 2017 pauluskirche bern
nicht nur christian auch die
reformierten kirchen bern jura solothurn
wollen sich reformieren
heute finde deshalb ein großes
kirchenfest stadt vision 21 zusammen mit
der bekannten pfarrerin sibylle vor
bestreitet christian wald die einen von
neun gottesdiensten in der stadt vor
ungewohnt vielen menschen
[Musik]
der gottesdienst soll interaktiv und
zukunftsweisend sein smartphones kommen
zum zug
das publikum hat das thema bestimmt die
wahrheit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie haben sie es mit der wahrheit
ich jedenfalls habe heute morgen schon
einmal gelogen
ich habe in den spiegel geschaut und mir
gesagt nein du hast keine angst so
vielen fremden menschen zu sprechen
[Musik]
am schlimmsten ist es ja nicht einmal
dann wenn wir statt einem jahr ein nein
sagen sondern dann wenn wir uns die
eigene realität ein bisschen aufpimpen
es ist gefährlich wenn jemand meint er
würde die wahrheit besitzen gerade die
geschichte unserer kirche zeigt wie
verhängnisvolles sein kann wenn man
meint im besitz der wahrheit zu sein
[Musik]
und jetzt brauchen sie ihr smartphone
wir sammeln ihre fürbitte anliegen mit
einem programm nehmen sie ihren browser
auf ihrem smartphone
die internetseite die sie auch wählen
ist www.cnty.com ja jetzt geht's los
unglaublich wie viele anliegen
versammelt sind wenn so viele menschen
zusammen bilden wollen
posten sie auch weiterhin unter dem
hashtag wie hast du es mit der wahrheit
bringen sie ihren widerspruch zum
ausdruck das interessiert uns sehr dass
diese predigt dieser gottesdienst noch
eine weile weiter geht in der virtuellen
welt
[Musik]
eine gelungene angelegenheit findet
christian walther besonders dass die
kirche endlich einmal öffentlich
zusammenstehe debatten führe
und nicht jeder wie häufig üblich nur
für sich schaut
[Musik]
doch bald die wäre nicht bald die bühne
holen würde nicht einen schritt weiter
gehen wollte eigentlich mit der
katholiken machen und damit noch nicht
meister oder waren nicht nur gott
alleine im laden also für mich für mich
ist das noch wichtig oder religion in
der öffentlichkeit vertreten hat einfach
als auch kliniken gemeinsam das dann
muss ich über die ich nie dran zu
russland
[Musik]
christian wald die ist dort wo er sich
wohlfühlt unter den menschen dort wo
etwas läuft und wo er seine ganz
persönliche vision für die zukunft der
kirche am besten spürt und die wäre
[Musik]
zwei orten wo man gott garantiert findet
so in die zukunft bitte fremde also
bekannt und wenn man daran erkennen dass
waren regelmäßig frische zukunft und für
die frauen der lügt wenn man kann nicht
einen gott und ich wünsche mir dass vor
allem dass man dran bleibt oft fahre
hier sagt jetzt also hätte man zur
familie gründen und so probiert oft vor
dass man eigentlich mehr heimen ist aber
das okay also ich glaube ich kann gut
mit dem radweg der heimischen halle
überzeugt
[Musik]
fr
die
[Musik]
reporter wurde ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution